technik geräte werkzeuge
einrichtungsgegenstände vermutlich ist
jeder von euch schon mal durch seine
stadt gelaufen wenn gerade sperrmüll auf
den straßen stand oder war auf einem
wertstoffhof und hat gesehen welche
schätze und eigentlich noch brauchbare
gegenstände so weggeschmissen werden und
nicht haben schon immer schrottplätze
fasziniert wo man sich einfach für
irgendwas aussuchen darf und wie cool
wärs denn die teilweise kaputten und
verrosteten sachen einfach zu reparieren
und ein bisschen aufhübschen und diese
dann gewinnbringend zu verkaufen wie
viel arbeit ist das welche schätze
findet man auf dem schrottplatz die
keiner mehr will und vor allem wie viel
geld kann ich damit verdienen in einer
woche dieses video wird unterstützt von
annie finn mehr infos wie euch anything
bei zu hohen raten kreditzinsen helfen
kann gibt es später im video
[Musik]
ich bin also auf der suche nach dem
perfekten short schrott kann in
deutschland an schrottplätzen und
wertstoffhöfen abgegeben werden wo er
dann sortiert und als rohmaterial zum
einschmelzen weiterverkauft wird aber
anders als in den usa wo die leute
regelmäßig zu schrottplätzen pilgern um
günstig an noch gute ware zu kommen darf
man in deutschland nicht ein bereits vom
wertstoffhof mitnehmen zum einen weil
bei solchen aktionen der
verletzungsgefahr besteht und zum
anderen sind die höfe eigentlich sogar
dazu verpflichtet den schrott zu
recyceln egal ob er noch funktioniert
oder nicht am recyclinghof in meiner
heimatstadt habe ich trotzdem schon
gesehen die menschen mitnehmen dürfen
und heute ist einer der drei tage in der
woche an denen er kurz mal geöffnet hat
und doch geschlossen scheinbar ist hier
erst am 12 erst weihnachten zu ende
also für mich die suche einen tag später
durch die malerische landschaft weit in
das 20 minuten entfernte nachbar es
drauf indem der recyclinghof zweimal die
woche exakt drei stunden geöffnet hat
und tatsächlich die sterne stehen
richtig es ist geöffnet mal schauen
welche endlose weiten voller potenziell
wertvollen schätzen da auf uns warten
die wir einfach so kostenlos mitnehmen
können leider haben wertstoffhöfe hier
keine telefonnummer denn sonst hätte
schon viel früher herausgefunden dass
das hier ein bisschen strenger mit dem
abhol verbot genommen wird und ich also
mit leeren händen dasteht wie ich wer
kann das denn sein ich will doch nur ein
bisschen müll da ich nun schon im
besagten nachbardorf war treffe ich mich
privat mit meinem kumpel franz und der
meinte ehrte noch ordentlich zeigt dass
entrümpelt werden muss also betrete ich
die heiligen hallen holz stroh ein pferd
und altbackene werkzeuge und andere fast
geschichtsträchtiger gegenstände die
teilweise noch immer verwendung finden
aber teilweise eben auch nicht ich
erwarte also zwei gänzlich verrostete
spitzhacken ohne stiel eine alte pfeile
einer blechschere die durch den rost
nicht mal mehr aufgeht sowie eine
lichtmaschine und einem dynamo also zwei
stromgeneratoren zusätzlich haben wir
hier einen manuellen holz bohrer und ein
fast antikes telefon aus längst
vergangenen zeiten oben drauf haben noch
zwei defekte elektroteile im keller
meine eltern gefunden und zwar einmal
nennen baustrahler mit einem übel
heftigen wackelkontakt er das teil
einfach nutzlos macht und ein heizlüfter
der zwar immer noch heißt aber halt die
lust nicht raus oder legen ventilator
kaputte sondern so ich finde das ist
schon eine heftige ausbeute am
krassesten finde ich dass hier das
sollen telefon sein das über hundert
jahre alt ist und es sieht einfach nur
wild aus gibt es auch hinweise darauf
wie alt das genau sein konnte und von
wem das gemacht wurde und so weiter und
so fort ist muss ich später noch mal
recherchieren und super spannend findet
auch diesen holz bohrer der ebenfalls
das über 100 jahre altes ich bin
mittlerweile ja wieder in meiner wohnung
in köln und ich denke in köln gibt es
ganz viele leute diese antike hitze
sachen richtig cool finden und dafür
hoffentlich richtigen batzen geld
erlassen wird am leichtesten ist es aber
glaube ich erst mal diese ganzen
rostigen werkzeuge hier zu nehmen und
auf hochglanz zu polieren dann noch
neuen stil und neuen griff dazu zu
machen und das dann direkt auf ebay zu
stellen
[Musik]
also fahren wir direkt mal an denen die
post hier von abzubekommen ich habe hier
zwar einen rost entfernen aber es gibt
noch eine viel coolere und auch ich
glaube effizientere variante und zwar
die elektrolyse wo man mit hilfe von
strom den rost einfachen weg wandern
lässt das mache ich zum ersten mal uns
dafür brauche ich eine große wanne eine
rostfreie stück mit halt dass ich mir
hier noch auf eine richtige größe
zuschneiden ein päckchen backpulver ein
netzteil mit dem man den strom
einstellen kann und einen guten schluck
wasser in die wanne wasser ist echt
schwer okay ich habe keinen plan wie
immer stärker selbst einmal das netzteil
jahren jetzt wird ein bisschen
kompliziert es muss ich einmal so ein
ding darüber lägen für die anode da muss
ich jeweils wir so eine enge bauen ich
nochmal diese platzierung den radio
abzuschneiden das ist ja theoretisch
eigentlich wie dafür geschaffen jetzt
erstmal diese pfeile zum beispiel machen
will dann bin ich mir jetzt im konstrukt
zurecht und das gestellt was dann genau
der richtige sein dass ich dann hier so
ein ding
ins wasser hängen kann jetzt ist das
alles endlich unter wasser ich habe
jetzt einfach direkt natron genommen und
nicht backpulver ich glaube dass müssen
zu wenig
[Musik]
so jetzt geht einen strom da werde ich
mir jetzt kein auch schon gestellt zu
recht mit dem ich dann dieses opfer
metall reinhängen kann dass man den
ganzen rost ansaugen wird quasi
irgendwie so ungefähr ob das ein stück
metall einmal der minuspol kommen jetzt
quasi hier direkt dran also daran wo die
rostigen sachen hängen und der plus
bekommt dann quasi als opfer stück waren
das den ganzen heraus absaugen wird mit
wasserstoff entstehen das explodieren
können deswegen sehen wir übrigens auch
nach freien luft die man ein bisschen
gras nicht gefehlt kribbelt schon ein
bisschen was
[Musik]
in diesem zeitraum erkennt man extrem
gut wie ein magischer so existiert von
verrosteten objekt hin zu unserem opfer
metall das den rost aufnehmen soll
dieses kleine teil denkt sich einfach so
ok muss los anni warte ich hab noch was
auf dem herd jedoch nicht okay
[Musik]
während sich der rost also ganz langsam
über mehrere stunden ablöst widmen wir
uns wieder unserem wohl
außergewöhnlichsten von dem telefon bzw
fernsprecher aus einer vergangenen welt
hatte mir wurde gesagt dass ein telefon
also ich hätte gerne eine jahreszahl
weil das jeder kultur antike aus alte
harris ist ultra graphen auf die grünen
kommen 800 eben heute geld ist voll
langweilig
das 1000 18 jahren ist also ich kann
mich dass die außen aus 1800 irgendwas
ist ein ich glaube
wenn er wies entfernt frech
verspricht einmal richtig krachen
just diese ist diese glocken
ja gut wie fix man sitzt
also der habe das was das urteil ist auf
jeden fall ganze menge rost von unseren
objekten abgegangen ja ich will jetzt
nicht unbedingt einmal somit den hinten
rein auch wenn es theoretisch glaube ich
gar nicht mal so gefährlich werden und
jetzt können nicht eigentlich einmal
hochleben und dann kommt noch mal alles
zum vorschein
also es sind immer noch mega voraus also
ist es nicht aber ich glaube der
restposten lässt sich jetzt gleich
leicht abbürsten sowas kommt man als
handtuch ganze draht kommt weg dann lag
da noch irgendeine pfeile drin die muss
jetzt auch noch kurz bergen recht
ordentlich besser geworden glaube ich
also ist schon echt noch viel rost ran
aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen wie
der jetzt leichter abzulösen sein wird
und natürlich auch schon zum großteil
weggegangen ist davor war er richtig
viel post ran
ok dann probiere ich das überhaupt das
funktioniert ob er überhaupt irgendwas
abgehen jetzt gleich
ok dann gehen uns ab der otheros gehe
jetzt weg und zurück bleibt das schwarze
stahl glaube ich oh ja und da kommt ja
sogar selber den stall schon zum
vorschein das ist richtig anstrengend
aber ist auch super das hättest fragen
die immer mehr einfach da eine saubere
spitzt zum vorschein kommt
irgendwann wurde mir das viel herum
gebürstet mit der stadt löste aber ein
bisschen zu blöd und ich habe mir
richtiges werkzeug geholt und damit geht
es dann auch schon viel schneller
[Musik]
so wie jetzt dieses schöne
mittelalterliche verdeckte finish hier
haben wollen würde könnte man das jetzt
geschlossen zieht auch cool aus wenn es
jetzt etwas mit historischen wert wenn
wir nicht aufsteigen lassen da ich das
allerdings möglichst frisch verkaufen
möchte ich jetzt einfach noch mal drüber
damit das ding wirklich schon glatt
poliert
die spitzhacke werde ich aber jetzt
erstmal pausieren da ich dafür später
schwerere geschütze auffahren muss ich
denke aber der vergleich mit der noch
vor rosteten blechschere macht trotzdem
schon deutlich was wir hier alles
rausgeholt haben und um die blechschere
mit der mann tatsächlich dünne
metallplatten also bleche schneiden
könnte wenn sie nicht so verrostet wäre
um die kümmern wir uns als nächstes
[Musik]
ich komme ja bei einer blechschere mit
dem schleif aufsatz leider nicht in die
ecken herein deswegen werde jetzt einmal
diese ultra alte und relativ verrostete
schrauben lösen das hat auch schon mal
gut geklappt doch jetzt haben wir quasi
die ganze einzelteile und jetzt werde
ich die noch mal schön find aber nicht
säubern
[Musik]
so die schere ist fertig abgeschliffen
ok damit ist die blechschere fertig
macht auf jeden fall jetzt im
brauchbaren eindruck hier im
vorher-nachher-vergleich erkennt man
sehr gut dass unter all dem schmutz und
ruß das jahrzehnte alte eisen immer noch
funkelt wie neu das wichtigste ist aber
natürlich das optische sondern ob sie
hat auch wirklich blech schneiden kann
und damit hat sie gar kein problem das
ist jetzt ein abfall stück das er schon
ewigkeiten rumliegt und das mit der
blechnerei mitzuschneiden
ist kommt sie also würde ich sagen haben
uns damit direkt einen verkauf machen
das was ich hier mache also alte sachen
zu nehmen und zu reparieren ist
eigentlich genau das gegenteil von dem
was die meisten inklusive mir selbst
noch mal so machen nach drei oder vier
jahren ist und computer veraltet und man
kauft sich einen neuen ganze 42 prozent
der deutschen nutzen für solche
anschaffungen übrigens ratenzahlungen
oder mit anderen worten nennt kredit den
man zurückzahlen muss und jetzt kommt
das ziemlich genial ist ins spiel und
zwar ende finden der sponsor des
heutigen videos der zu hohe zinsen
einfach beseitigen kann in der platte
die einfach ein foto des noch offenen
ratenkauf hoch und anything prüft dann
ob sie euch einen günstigeren zins
bieten können
nur wenn ja erhaltet ihr ein angebot
sieht wie viele im vergleich zur alten
ratenzahlungen sparen würde und könnte
den alten kredit direkt über die app
ablösen der alte und zu teure kredit ist
dann geschichte und jetzt halt nur noch
die günstigeren raten über die app
könnte dann auch jederzeit die höhe der
ratenzahlung anpassen oder sogar eine
raten pause einlegen wenn ihr gerade den
finanziellen engpass hat klickt auf den
ersten link in der video beschreibung
und da der 20 euro was mit dem coach
tommy das ganze ist kostenlos also
probiert es doch gerne mal aus wenn der
offene ratenzahlungen oder sonstige
kredite habt ganz wichtig ist natürlich
auch die produktbilder leute wollen
sehen was sie da kaufen vielleicht mein
zollstock geben damit man den eindruck
kriegt wie groß das alles ist
ich denke auch dass es besonders wichtig
sein könnte die schneiden zu zeigen so
aber nimmt pc als ich denn jetzt muss
man eben etwas auf ebay ein hier oben
ist schon verkaufen ihr fremd zum
produktnamen ok blechschere werkzeug
blechschere genau so was kosten die
normal so hier nagelneue 16 euro 20 euro
für zwei stück sieben euro aber hier
mitgeboten okay das ist bieten sogar
leute auf blech schweren das heißt es
gibt einen markt für blechschäden ja
diese drei euro aber die ist auch echt
träsch die er ist für 9 euro drin okay
also wenn das teil euro wäre dann kriegt
man dafür auf jeden fall auch so viel
alte eisen schere blechschere klempner
hält das ist genau das gleiche denken
dass fast das gleiche zeit das ist für
17 euro drin also blechschere alt
werkzeug ausfuhren eisen restauriert die
schläfen und vom verkäufer
generalüberholt das kann man sagen ich
habe es auf jede generalüberholt
frostfrei und richtig geschliffen diese
alte blechschere wurde zusammen mit
anderen gegenständen gefunden deren
baujahr anhand von seriennummern und co
auf ca 1890 datiert werden konnte so
wurde generalüberholt und ist nun wieder
100 prozent einsatzbereit das klingt
doch gut startpreisen euro okay man alle
erstes über inserate blechschere
größenvergleich mehrere bilder kohl okay
ich bin gespannt und hoffentlich kommen
ins bald ein paar anfragen oder so
moment ich hab mir das angeschaut und
wir haben einfach ein gebot und ich bin
gespannt wie hoch ein euro meist jemand
geht das mindestangebot und jemand der
willy betsch ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass irgendwann wäre braucht und jetzt
holt man das ist der beginn am ende hier
nicht mit null euro raus sondern
mindestens mit einem und das ist für
dieses experiment schon
also das motiviert mich jetzt aber
weiterhin also morgen
ohne umwege wir nun für den rest der
spitzhacke die flex also der
winkelschleifer ausgepackt um die kanten
wieder kantig und die spitzen wieder
spitz zu schleifen sowie alles auf
hochglanz zu polieren und zwar im
wahrsten sinne des wortes
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so sind jetzt die fertige spitzhacke aus
ich sag mal so ist es auf jeden fall
definitiv schwieriger als in minecraft
danke das gleichsam
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt gerade unsere
marketing-strategie büro mein pc wo ich
mich jetzt wieder ein ebay einloggen
werde und anschauen werde was schlauer
ist macht jetzt mehr sind das teilen ja
einfach so zu verkaufen oder können wir
vielleicht noch mehr geld machen wenn
ich jetzt einmal auch noch ein spiel da
für bau und wir das dann quasi als
gesamtes spitzhacke verkaufen also eher
verkauft eine spitzhacke 25 euro mit
griff dann werden hier im live ticker
hier oben quasi auch mal sieben euro
eingestellt und will ich sagen stell
dich jetzt aber mal so rein ohne stiel
und wenn der käufer finden muss ich kein
machen wenn man käufer nicht finden dann
machen
wir die fotos des sogenannten pickles
entstehen also ohne stiel hierbei
versuche ich besonders die spiegelung zu
betonen die natürlich wenn wir mal
ehrlich sind im gebrauch ohnehin nicht
relevant sein wird aber vielleicht läuft
das ganze erkunden an in der
zwischenzeit gab es übrigens schon das
zweite gebot auf die blechschere erhöht
von einem euro auf 1 euro 50 das ist
zwar noch nicht viel aber es gibt
immerhin schon einen kleinen bieterkampf
und wir können gespannt sein wie weit
der noch nach oben getrieben wird bevor
die auktion abläuft ich habe jetzt
übrigens mal diesen pickel hier einfach
komplett unbehandelt reingestellt im
gegensatz zu diesen wunderschönen
glänzenden ist er jetzt kommt mit rost
ein baum herauszufinden ob die mühe hier
vielleicht einfach umsonst warum ich mit
horst vielleicht genau den gleichen
preis bekommen ich habe mir jetzt mal
schon dieses fast antike telefonieren
ich wollte das eigentlich reparieren ich
habe allerdings nichts dass im internet
gefunden dann hätte ich vielleicht
gewusst was da fehlt wie das alles
funktioniert und so weiter und so fort
vielleicht schaltkreise anschauen können
aber so häufig davon jetzt kein plan ich
könnte jetzt einfach willkürlich dadurch
strom drauf geben und schauen was
passiert dabei besteht natürlich aber
auch die gefahr dass ist einfach grille
deswegen habe ich mir auch überlegt dass
es am lukrativsten wäre das einfach so
einzustellen noch ein bisschen reinigen
mit luft bei uns weiter und so fort dass
es schöner aussieht uns dann darauf
hoffen dass es ein sammler findet
mittlerweile gibt es auch schon das
erste gebot auf die spitze axt und wie
es um das telefon bestellt ist werden
wir auch bald sehen kümmern wir uns aber
zunächst um den holz bohrer der als
erstes in seine einzelteile zerlegt wird
und danach ebenfalls über nacht im
elektrolyse bar seine rost schicht
verliert
es ist auf jeden fall natürlich wie man
sie super viel hass in diesem wasser
rinnt mir und den hieraus der täter
wissen kann man eigentlich relativ
leicht abwischen sogar mit zehn fingern
das ist sehr cool aus mit dem verliert
ich habe nämlich erst überlegt ob man
nicht vielleicht dieses schwarze dunkle
finish lassen soll aber ich finde es mit
halterung dass man solch ein geiler ich
werde das aber diesmal schon entfernen
und zwar nur mit der bürste und nicht
irgendwie richtig schleifen damit man
hier perfekte dass ich noch mal richtig
schön behält
[Musik]
nachdem der rost vom bohrer abgebürstet
wurde werden auch die holzelemente
abgebürstet denn genau wie beim
schleifen mit hierbei der
oberflächlicher schmutz entfernt und die
lebendige farbe kommt zum vorschein aber
gleichzeitig bleibt die raue struktur
des holzes erhalten einen kurzen schlaf
gang gibt es danach aber trotzdem die
beiden heutzutage sind behandelt
allerdings noch nicht komplett denn
damit einfach so richtig das leben
rauskommt finden sich das jetzt noch mal
schön ein mit einem öl damit dass man
sie behandelt es bisher ein robuster ist
das sind die farben mehr rauskommt das
volle restaurations programm hierfür sie
fangen an mit der spitze hier man sieht
man schon wie viel hübscher das direkt
aus sieht einfach ein bisschen öl drauf
ist jetzt im griff er sieht auch die
hier direkt viel schöner aus richtiger
klappt moment
so dass wir jetzt eine weile einziehen
da bin will ich es nochmal ein und dann
kommen zusammen bauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe jetzt gerade produktfotos von
unserem wunderschönen holz bohrer
gemacht und ich finde der ist richtig
richtig cool gebäuden die farbe ist
richtig hilft jetzt mittlerweile sogar
die ganze nägel und schrauben sind jetzt
horst fried kommt mittlerweile jetzt wo
ich das rückt bilder macht und so weiter
und so fort und die dann quasi ein
computer hochladen und das einstellt
dann entwickelt sich eine richtige china
so das fühlt sich schon fast
professionell an als würde ich mich
beruflich machen was nicht als
allerdings auch interessiert bevor ich
das teil hier verkaufe möglichst noch
gerne probieren weil ich finde das echt
ziemlich crazy kann dann fast gar nicht
vorstellen jemand jetzt hier mit preisen
locken soll also gut aus können sich
jetzt ein dass es ein bisschen speisen
aber darum ging es ja auch gar nicht es
muss jetzt auch kein meisterwerk werden
und es geht aber nicht auf was ich nicht
zu tief und nicht so viel auf einmal
machen ja geht dadurch wie sie gar nix
das eher cool ist ein bisschen wie ein
überdimensionierter korkenzieher es
funktioniert ist komplett krass also man
kann damit einfach löcher bohren ohne
strom ist für viele von euch
wahrscheinlich gar nicht persönlich
finde es super cool ich habe den
holzbohlen gestellt und ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich kenne es fast ein
bisschen schade wenn ich kenne loswerden
würde weil ich den echt ein stück weiter
ins herz geschlossen habe ich finde es
echt cool weil sowas nahezu haben mit
dem jahr 200 jahre oder noch länger
gearbeitet haben ich finde es wirklich
ultra cool und auf ebay gibt es auch
mehrere von den zu deko zwecken das
problem dass sie dann also bei staubig
und verrostet das würde ich mir nicht in
die wohnung hängen wollen während ich
sowas weil das halt wirklich knallige
farben hat schon echt super cool findet
mittlerweile haben wir übrigens ein paar
leute geschrieben wegen des telefons und
auch was die jungs angeht ist das
telefon das erfolgreichste meiner
inserate aber der grund warum sich die
leute bei mir gemeldet haben ist nicht
der den ich mir erhofft hatte hier
schreibt zum beispiel jemand hallo bin
telefon sammler und musste etwas
schmunzeln wegen der beschreibung das
telefon fragment ist ein op 33 das von
den 30er jahren bis ende der 60er jahre
für die deutsche bahn gebaut wurde im
vollständigen zustand ist noch eine
metall habe drauf und ein bakelit
höherem ihr exemplar ist wie an zwei
stellen zu sehen ist aus 1958 und auch
die verwendung bei der damaligen
bundesbahn db ist ersichtlich mit dem
aufpreis wird es leider sicherlich
nichts werden einerseits schade dass es
nicht so alt ist wie ich dachte
andererseits ist es halt echt ultra kur
so eine expertise zugekommen weil ich
persönlich werde niemals drauf gekommen
und das telefon hat eigentlich mal so
ausgesehen man sieht zwar die kurbel
aber die glocken und alles sind nun
einmal verkleidet hinterher irgendwie
logisch ich passe jetzt mal direkt die
beschreibung an uns die preise weil dann
ist es natürlich nicht so viel wie
gedacht komplett krank innerhalb
kürzester zeit ist jetzt quasi
blechschere von 1 euro 50 auf einfach 6
euro hoch die ist noch ungefähr 45
minuten drin ich bin hier sprachen aber
der pfalz weiter so wenige möglich ist
und wie weit es noch gehen wird so und
nun zu den elektrogeräten meiner eltern
und den stromgeneratoren also den
baustrahler hier könnte ich vermutlich
echte sie reparieren der hat einfach nur
ein wackelkontakt und beim heizlüfter
denke ich auch dass ich herausfinden
könnte warum sich der lüfter nicht dreht
um ihn wieder zum laufen zu kriegen aber
hier macht das deutsche gesetz
vermutlich zum glück uns einen strich
durch die rechnung denn wenn ich
jemanden jetzt etwas verkaufe was ich
repariert habe muss ich gewährleisten
dass das ding sicher ist und wenn
dadurch jetzt was abbrennt muss ich
dafür haften vor allem aber bin ich kein
gelernter elektriker und deshalb wäre es
auch recht verantwortungslos weshalb man
sowas lieber von profis reparieren
lassen sollte zumindest wenn man
verkaufen möchte und nun das fazit wir
gingen die bieter kämpfe der auktion aus
und wie viel geld war meine mühe vor der
arbeit nun wert auf dem marktplatz die
blechschere ist abgelaufen und wechselt
seinem besitzer für sechs euro was ich
persönlich echt krass finne war für neun
oder acht euro kennt man schon nagelneue
aber wir haben jetzt die anderen sachen
abgeschnitten ja die spitzhacke hier hat
sage und schreibe einen ganzen euro
erzielt das ist schon ein bisschen
bitter weil das war echt richtig viel
arbeit und ich glaube und die ganzen
stromkosten für die gerätschaften und
die ganzen schleifpapier die haben schon
mehr als 1 euro gekostet also für 1 euro
würde schon fast lieber selber gehalten
aber das kann sich auch nicht bringt das
war es tatsächlich sieben euro ja woran
sie fragen sich natürlich immer woran
sich das vielleicht habt ihr ja ein paar
tipps in den kommentaren immerhin darf
ich diesen wunderschönen holz bohrer
behalten und auch diesen wunderschönen
pickel hier ja so sind aus check gerne
any finden über den link in der video
beschreibung ab wenn ihr laufen der
ratenzahlungen habt und geld sparen
möchte und dann will ich sagen sie uns
demnächst mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]